bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct du sénat pour la séance des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
beaucoup de questions adressées au
gouvernement aujourd'hui notamment sur
l'espionnage des états unis au sein de
l'union européenne c'est richard yung le
sénateur socialiste qui ouvrira tout à
l'heure par ce point sur l'espionnage et
bien cette séance des questions
d'actualité
à noter cet après midi ici au sénat
trois interrogations
deux sénateurs après le rapport dû
débuter dureront sur les infrastructures
de transport dans les collectivités
territoriales il ya eu beaucoup
d'interrogations ici au sénat bien sûr
les freins apporté à des grands projets
d'infrastructures de transport
voilà parmi les points qui seront donc
développé tout à l'heure pendant cette
séance des questions d'actualité
on commence notre émission avec le
sénateur socialiste françois marc
bonjour je rappelle que vous êtes ici au
sens la commission des finances du sénat
est bien le rapporteur du budget un
poste clé et après la séance des
questions d'actualité
et bien il y aura au sénat un débat
d'orientation budgétaire alors c'est
vrai que il ya encore beaucoup
d'interrogations sur le budget 2014
beaucoup d'aléas notamment autour des 6
milliards de recettes supplémentaires
que le gouvernement doit trouver où on a
envie de tout simplement de vous
demander où on va trouver ces 6
milliards
à vrai dire cet après midi nous avons
deux débats le premier sur la loi de
règlement d'exercice 2012 où on va
clôturer l'exercice et analyser les
enseignements à tirer
et puis effectivement on va aussi
débattre des perspectives données 2014
en essayant de s'inspirer de ce qui se
passe en 2013 parce que l'exercice
budgétaire est en cours avec des
conséquences qui n'était pas anticipé de
la crise économique sur le plan
budgétaire notamment ce plan des
recettes et il nous faut donc nous
préparer à 2014 en essayant de prévoir
les moyens de respecter la trajectoire
qu'on s'est fixés puisque l'objectif
c'est bien d'arriver à un déficit 0 en
2017 je rappelle que le déficit était de
87 milliards en 2012
il faut arriver à zéro c'est dire
l'effort considérable qui à accomplir et
pour préparer ce budget 2014 on a à
tracer les grandes lignes sur la
suggestion du gouvernement et aussi à
commencer à réfléchir effectivement aux
pistes de recettes nouvelles et surtout
aux pistes d'économies puisque ce sont
les dépenses qui vont surtout être
impactés l'année prochaine est ce qu'on
va faire
est ce qu'on va pouvoir éviter une
hausse des impôts pour les ménages
je crois que le président de la
république a été clair de ce point de
vue il s'agit de se placer dans l'idée
que c'est aujourd'hui le chapitre der
des dépenses qui est à mettre à
contribution donc il y aura des
économies sur les dépenses de l'ordre de
14 milliards au total
et il y aura également à chercher du
côté des recettes au niveau des niches
fiscales au niveau d'un certain nombre
de programmes que l'on peut solliciter
aussi sur le plan je pense des recettes
du côté social d'un certain nombre de
solutions à trouver mais je le rappelle
il ne s'agit pas aujourd'hui de prendre
les décisions
de quel chapitre en sollicite il s'agit
de définir les équilibres globaux pour
oui mais c'est vrai qu'on attend un
petit peu des détails on a tous lu
évidemment le rapport de la cour des
comptes qui demande 28 milliards
d'économies en 2014 et en 2015 donc le
gouvernement à 10 20 milliards pour
l'année 2014
a priori on voit aussi que peut-être les
recettes des impôts notamment sur les
entreprises en 2013 vont être moins à ce
que vous avez des informations là-dessus
est ce que finalement le gouvernement
qui comptait sur 16 milliards de
recettes cette année sur l'impôt sur les
sociétés eh bien il va - va rentrer dans
les caisses de l'état
je crois qu'on en saura plus à la fin de
l'été car les derniers chiffres sont le
très curieux puisque autant mois d'avril
les chiffres étaient très mauvais autant
au mois de mai
les recettes ont été plutôt satisfaisant
puisque en tva est un impôt société on
semble dégager plus de recettes que ce
qui était anticipé c'est donc dire que
avant le mois de septembre on aura pas
une vision claire de ce que sera
l'exercice 2013 en matière de recettes
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que la crise
est plus dur qu'on ne l'avait anticipé
plus longue et que dès lors il y aura
effectivement comme vous laissiez
entendre des recettes en moins et qu'il
faudra se préparer pour compenser 2014 à
trouver le complément nécessaire mais ça
va être l'objet de la loi de finances
pour l'instant les propositions ils sont
beaucoup d'économies à trouver non
frangins marque beaucoup d'économies
wifi si la non mais on sait bien que ça
va être difficile puisque on a un
déficit considérable que le gouvernement
précédent s'était efforcé de réduire
mais qu'il a eu peine à à ce qu'il ait
eu peine à faire et vous ici oui bien
sûr 87 milliards de déficit c'est énorme
et atteindre donc zéro déficit en 2017
c'est un effort durable qu'il faut
réaliser sur plusieurs années donc les
deux années les plus difficiles ce sera
probablement cet effort vous semble
durable est ce qui vous semble te nabeul
temps il impose de restriction
d'économies à faire aujourd'hui
l'équation est simple
c'est que la france est engagée
l'ensemble des observateurs les acteurs
européens
les milieux financiers nous regardent et
donc je crois qu'on n'a pas vraiment le
choix
quant à ses efforts qu'il nous faut
accomplir donc je pense que c'est
réalisable
si la croissance comme celle annoncée
par les organismes de prévisions revient
2000 début 2014
on doit être en mesure de satisfaire à
l'objectif de ramener le déficit en
dessous des 3%
sinon en 2015 puisque l'europe nous
autorise à aller en 2015 peut-être plus
tôt c'est en tout cas ce que le
gouvernement veut faire dans son projet
de budget puisqu'il veut ramener les
visites à à moins de 3% fin 2014 donc
c'est une ambition très forte qui est
annoncé pierre gattaz le nouveau patron
du medef voudrait que le gouvernement
est bien propose 100 milliards
d'économies sur cinq ans pour les
entreprises 100 milliards ventilé à
égalité entre une baisse des cotisations
sociales et des impôts qu'elles
répondent vous apportez vous aujourd'hui
à pierre gattaz eh bien il faut savoir
que après le rapport qui a conduit donc
à l'élaboration du cic eux on a convenu
que 20 milliards dans l'immédiat c'est
est un objectif déjà conséquent c'est
sur cette trajectoire gouvernement a
placé la barre donc si d'autres
économies sont réalisables pourquoi pas
mais déjà 20 milliards c'est pas mal dès
lors monsieur gattaz veut en arrivant à
son poste donné des gages à ses soutiens
et aux patrons de france en indiquant
qu'il va être exigeant vis-à-vis du
gouvernement ce qui est tout à fait dans
son rôle mais qu'ils sachent que le
gouvernement a déjà pris la mesure de
l'effort à accomplir a mis le cic en
place avec 20 milliards en perspective
et qui sait si demain on ira pas jusqu
au 30 milliards qui était souhaité dans
le fameux rapport dont on s'est inspiré
pour faire ce séisme vous êtes de ceux
qui pensent à gauche qu'il faut
améliorer la compétitivité des
entreprises françaises et que le retour
de la croissance passera justement par
une meilleure compétitivité de nos
entreprises
on ne peut pas dire les choses autrement
l'emploi bien des entreprises
il nous faut avoir une compétitivité qui
soit tout à fait satisfaisante
les choses commencent à s'améliorer
puisque avec les augmentations de
salaires en allemagne et la mise en
place du cic eux il semble aujourd'hui
apparaître que le coût du travail en
france est en train de se rapprocher du
coût du travail en allemagne pour
l'industrie manufacturière donc on est
sur une trajectoire à mon avis vertueuse
en la matière et dès lors on peut penser
qu'on sera une situation de plus forte
compétitivité à l'export
philippe marini le président de votre
commission des finances est bien
voudrais faire un grand nettoyage des
niches fiscales
est-ce que vous allez vous marchez dans
son sens vous l'accompagnez sur cette
volonté lui dit que ça pourrait
permettre de gagner 7 à 8 milliards par
an je pense que les niches fiscales sont
effectivement une source majeure de
d'économies possibles pour le budget de
l'état
je me réjouis que à droite en france
aujourd'hui on a en viennent à une
position de sélectionner les niches
parce que jusque-là à droite on
entendait surtout parlé du rabot et on
voulait raboter toutes les niches de 2 %
5% 10%
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui si l'on
considère qu'il ya des bonnes niches et
des moins bonnes mais vous avez que dans
chaque niche il ya un lobby qui se cache
dans chaque guichet un lobby mais il est
dans le rôle des politiques de trancher
et de préserver les niches utile et les
niches socialement utiles et d'éliminer
les niches qui n'apportent aucune plus
value et un rapport qui a été fait il
est sur la table aujourd'hui il est
connu et on a classé les niches en trois
catégories
et il y en a certaines de catégorie 3 il
y en a deux catégories une donc on va
essayer de s'attaquer prioritairement
aux niches inutiles ou inefficaces et à
mon avis on peut effectivement trouver
plusieurs milliards et ça va être le
rôle des parlementaires sont pensés
chercher c'est ce que vous allez faire
la même chose immense 1 607 ça va être
une des tâches principales de la
commission des finances que d'essayer de
sélectionner de faire un tri sélectif de
toutes ces niches fiscales et de générer
de par ce biais peut-être plusieurs
milliards d'euros d'économies françois
marc que vous allez poser tout à l'heure
une question dans l'hémicycle sur
l'industrie agroalimentaire qui
souffrent beaucoup en ce moment il ya
des licenciements assez massif dans ce
secteur là pourquoi cette industrie en
france et en touche et en ce moment
est-ce qu'elle n'est plus compétitif
justement et comment regagner des parts
de marché
c'est vrai que l'industrie
agroalimentaire et est un pôle de
résistance depuis des années parce que
la france a perdu depuis soixante-dix
mille neuf cent soixante dix la moitié
de ses emplois industriels mais
l'agroalimentaire résister et
aujourd'hui ça va pas non plus très bien
il ya nombreux dépôts de bilan des mises
en liquidation et dès lors on s'inquiète
des raisons de cette situation la
première est bien c'est qu'il ya une un
problème de compétitivité avec
l'allemagne
aujourd'hui sur l'agroalimentaire dans
les filières animales en particulier et
ceci du fait du coût du travail
il est anormal que aujourd'hui leur de
madoff soit payée 4 euros en allemagne
avec de la main d'oeuvre qui vient de
pays de l'est et que leur de main
d'oeuvre en france soit 13 ou 14 euros
donc il y a un différentiel la
inadmissible donc ça c'est un premier
levier c'est d'arriver à l'échelle
européenne en ciel est ce que ça va
passer notamment par le crédit impôt
compétitivité non ça va passer par une
action à l'échelle européenne qui visant
à instaurer un smic européen et visant à
affaire que la législation sur le
travail trouve un point d'équilibré qui
aujourd'hui n'est pas du tout atteint et
c'est je pense sur ce terrain qu'il faut
agir mais il ya aussi un problème
d'organisation des filières et je pense
que de ce point de vue le gouvernement à
la matière à agir pour mieux organiser
les filières de l'agroalimentaire et les
rendre plus compétitives et les
restructurer autant que de besoin
très bien m'écouter merci françois
marque on reviendra sur cette question
de l'agroalimentaire avec guillaume
garot le ministre de l'agro alimentaire
qui sera sur notre plateau tout à
l'heure ainsi que bernard cazeneuve le
ministre du budget et puis évidemment
d'autres sénateurs qui vont interpeller
cet après midi le gouvernement lors de
cette séance des questions d'actualité
une séance qui va commencer d'ici
quelques instants on vient de voir jean
pierre bel le président du sénat et bien
qu'ils se dirigeaient vers l'hémicycle
a priori il s'installe sur le plateau
l'endroit où il préside la séance est
donc cette ce que séance des questions
d'actualité va démarrer avec je vous les
livre solaire une question de richard
yong le sénateur socialiste qui
représentent les français de l'étranger
et il interpelle le gouvernement sur
l'espionnage de l'union européenne par
les états unis c'est thierry reportant
le ministre des affaires européennes qui
lui répondra parmi les autres thèmes et
bien examiner cet après midi par les
sénateurs pour ces questions d'actualité
je voulais dit aussi tout à l'heure il y
aura trois questions autour du rapport
sur les infrastructures de transport en
france il ya beaucoup de grogne ici au
sénat puisque des projets notamment deux
tgv sont gelés et évidemment les
sénateurs craignent pour leurs
collectivités territoriales et puis
bernard cazeneuve le ministre du budget
sera également interpellé sur des
questions budgétaires
on parlera également de la fin de vie
avec le sénateur ump gérard dériot on
parlera aussi des inondations dans le
sud ouest de la france il ya une dizaine
de jours et ça ça sera le sénateur
socialiste bertrand auban qui va
interpeller le gouvernement
donc vous le voyez des thèmes assez
varié autour de cette séance des
questions d'actualité voilà qui va
démarrer dans dans quelques instants
puisqu'on a vu le président du sénat
jean-pierre bel s'installer dans
l'hémicycle ce qui voudrait dire qu'ils
donnent le coup d'envoi de cette séance
peut-être qu'on attend encore quelques
membres de gouvernements quelques
ministres qui vont venir s'installer sur
les bancs du gouvernement et puis
effectivement france 3 qui diffusait
également comme public sénat et bien
cette séance des questions d'actualité
en direct françois qui doit rendre
l'antenne à france 2 pour le tour de
france donc vous voyez
chacun a ses petites intérêt à respecter
pour le début de cette séance des
questions d'actualité ici au
gouvernement alors
et à 16 heures et bien on se retrouvera
en direct sur ce plateau avec plusieurs
invités je voulais dit tout à l'heure
bernard cazeneuve donc le ministre du
budget on fera le point sur le débat
d'orientation budgétaire qui aura lieu
cet après midi à partir de 16h 30 dans
l'hémicycle du sénat
nous recevrons également guillaume garot
le ministre de l'agro alimentaire il y
aura une question posée par françois
marque sur de multiples plans massifs de
licenciement dans cette filière qui
souffre beaucoup
aujourd'hui en france on reviendra
également avec guillaume garot sur la
fère en gros puisque le tribunal de
commerce doit trancher demain sur les
plans de reprise qui ont été déposés au
tribunal de commerce
et puis on fera le point également sur
l'éviction le limogeage du gouvernement
de delphine batho puisque seront
présentes sur ce plateau et bien esther
benbassa sénatrice d'europe écologie les
verts
ici donc au sénat face à laurence
rossignol
ll est sénatrice socialiste elle aussi
porte parole du parti socialiste et
laurence rossignol et bien elle est
toujours intéressée de près de près à
toutes ces questions de l'écologie voilà
comme cette séance des questions
d'actualité
et bien ne démarre pas pour l'instant je
vous propose de regarder ce focus qui a
été tourné autour de la défense des aoc
en normandie on se retrouve tout de
suite après en direct à tout à l'heure